come on
assalamualaikum and welcome back to the
three Muslims now I'm sure many of you
have seen this video by Tam Khan on his
Instagram story which seemingly looks
like Andrew Tate has been released
thank you
foreign
is he was the one that originally posted
the video of him praying with Andrew
Tate in a mosque that went viral and
very soon after Andrew Tate publicly
came out about his conversion to Islam
additionally you'll also find updates
from sartorial shooter who is his right
hand guy the team myself and the other
two Muslims that are not in this video
again because it's very late right now
and I just wanted to quickly film this
we're in touch with oratorial as well
and he posts frequent updates on
Instagram and Twitter I want to make it
unequivocally clear that we don't know
anything yet nothing is confirmed
there's been nothing from any verified
media outlet that he has been released
but I wanted to go ahead and make this
video anyway just in case he is released
and the video by Tam Khan is actually
Andrew Tate being finally freed I wanted
to take this opportunity anyway to talk
about something that Andrew Tate
mentions a lot on Twitter 10 hours ago
he tweeted when Allah said I only
touched those I love I took the pain
like it was an honor byrero peace be
upon him yesterday he tweeted an Ayah or
a verse from the Quran saying truth is
common falsehood has vanished falsehood
is surely bound to vanish he also posted
a quote by
he wrote what can my enemies do to me my
Paradise is in my heart it is with me
wherever I go to imprison me is to
provide me with seclusion to send me
into Exile is to send me away in the
path of Allah
and to kill me is to make me a martyr
now it seems very clear that he has hope
he seems very level-headed and he seems
very innocent in what he's saying now
it's not in our place to judge whether
or not he's guilty because again the
truth will always come out from what's
apparent there's no evidence according
to his lawyer this is not what I'm
saying this is what Andrew Tate's lawyer
is saying very clearly publicly that
there's no evidence thus far and he said
this in Romanian court that there's no
evidence thus far
to prove the allegations against him are
true now forget even in Western Law in
Islamic law as well everyone is innocent
until proven guilty there has to be
evidence at least generally speaking and
has become clear that at the end of the
day the truth will always come out
regardless of the lies the hypocrisy the
slandering or anything that the media
tries to portray against him and anyone
else for that matter and I'm sure you
saw that he was either going in or out
of court that he was carrying the Quran
and he was walking with his brother
Tristan
I'm in the Quran we learn about you know
Yusuf Al Islam Prophet Joseph that Allah
talks about and we know the story about
how he was falsely accused and falsely
convicted for a crime that he didn't
commit and he was imprisoned now if this
happened to a prophet or messenger of
Allah of God what makes us think that us
laymen just regular men like Andrew Tate
or anyone would not be susceptible to
anything alike it's so audacious for us
to just come to terms with this false
notion that you know what innocent will
always be innocent and guilty will
always be guilty in this Dunya no that's
not the point of this life
wrongful convictions happened
and I'm not saying that he's innocent
and I'm not saying he's guilty but what
I am saying is at the end of the day if
you're truly innocent you will get
Justice and it might not be in this life
that's the harsh reality that a lot of
people have in comes to terms with
but if you're truly guilty even if
you're innocent in this life you're
going to be held accountable sometime or
another and the main message that I want
you guys to understand is till this
point if what Andrew Tate's lawyer is
saying it's true that there's no
evidence against him he's a Muslim
brother and regardless of the false
notion that a lot of people have about
him all we can do is rely on Allah on
God and leave it to him it's not up to
us to judge if he's guilty or not does
he deserve it or not truth shall become
very apparent and clear very soon and
falsehood will become completely exposed
very soon all we can do now is make Dua
for our brother and for justice for all
the innocent people that have been
wrongfully convicted or slandered or
accused of things that they didn't
commit these things happen we know they
do let's not cap we don't live in this
perfect beautiful rainbows and sunshine
type of world or Donia where Injustice
doesn't happen the prophet saws warned
specifically about these days that are
here right now once upon a time to come
so stay tuned we'll let you guys know if
there's any updates and show Allah for
more and as soon as we find anything out
from sartorial or from tamilcon or
anything like that we will let you guys
know keep Andrew taking your duas
and at the end of the day if you made it
this far comment down below hashtag free
top G and make sure you guys tune in
tonight at 6 p.m Eastern Standard Time
Wednesday night tonight for a live
stream very important video and with
that being said assalamu alaikum